we're very pleased and honored to have
as our keynote speaker professor TJ pen
pal our first political scientist giving
this John Whitney Hall lecture professor
penpal is the jack m4c professor of
political science at the University of
California at Berkeley and one of the
world's foremost authorities on the
politics and political economy of Japan
and of East Asia more generally and
there's much to say about professor pen
pal but because we're really here to
listen to him I'm going to keep my
introduction very short but I want to
bring to your attention three things
that come to mind when I think of
Professor pentel that distinguish him as
a great scholar of Japanese politics the
first is that he's prolific he's written
or edited 20 books a hundred 20 articles
more than anyone I can think of in in
this field the second thing is that
Professor penpal is drawn to puzzles
things that are curious things that
don't fit the Disciplinary template he's
a solid political scientist but he looks
at the world and sees how the world
doesn't really match what we were meant
to believe about it and then goes about
answering the questions that come to him
as he looks at the empirical world and
the third thing is that his vision his
intellectual vision is panoramic he's
taken in Japan into that vision compared
Japan with other advanced industrialized
countries but then he's also situated
Japan in Asia and thought about the
connections between Japan among all of
the Asian neighbors and then how that in
turn is situated in the world so some of
you might have noticed this was the the
P alliteration but all of this adds up
to a truly powerful impact on
both the discipline of political science
but also the way we think about Japan so
I'm really thrilled to introduce
professor penpal to you and looking very
much forward to what he's going to tell
us about dismantling Japanese
developmental ism before we welcome him
warmly I just need to give a quick
announcement his lecture is going to be
about 50 minutes long we're going to
have a few minutes for Q&A but don't
despair if you didn't get your question
in we're going to have to move things
along because we have a reception and
this will be your next opportunity to
talk with Professor penpal over a glass
of wine and some some appetizers so
please join me in welcoming professor
penpal to this podium thank you very
much princess it's a great pleasure for
me to be here I want to thank the
council on East Asian Studies I want to
thank Francis for inviting me I hadn't
realized that was the first political
scientist who to give this lecture but
it's a triple distinction to to be able
to do that and for those of you who are
in any way connected with Jack hall I
simply want to say that I did have the
good fortune to know him before his
death Jack was always a wonderful
inspiration I was the token youth on
various committees where he was the the
senior voice and I was always very
impressed with his scholarship and his
knowledge of Japan but one of the and
and for those of you who knew him you
will know that he was a incredible
anecdotal list and also a wonderful
punster in both Japanese and in English
but the one story that has always stuck
with me from his telling apparently he
was in Japan somewhere in the 1950s
probably just past the occupation lived
in a Japanese home had just taken his
Japanese bath it was a summer evening he
put on his yukata went out into the
garden and was looking up at a full moon
and staring at it the way so many
Japanese do when a young or rather an
elderly Japanese female neighbor looked
over the fence and said oh
son America d gwatsky gala mascot is
there a wheel is there a moon in the in
the united states and Jack was always
had the eye for that that distinctive
sense of where Japan in the u.s. get
together a word quickly about this
project it starts here primarily as a
project about Japan but it's part of a
larger book project that I'm working on
which is trying to look at how different
countries across the East Asia have been
subject to changing global pressures
about which I'll say a few minutes and
how countries that look the same at some
point in time usually around the 1970s
1980s have moved in very disparate
directions and I'm really working with
four pairs of countries Japan South
Korea as developmental regimes about
which I'll say a few things Burma North
Korea as to very odd ball non
economically oriented country's military
dictatorships etc China Vietnam as
communist countries that have adjusted
and then Indonesia Thailand military
countries struggling with democracy so
it's within that context that I'm trying
to raise this set of issues with you
today now what do I mean by all of this
let me start with this by posing what
might be thought of as three snapshots
of contemporary Japan the first of these
is simply the slow level of economic
growth in Japan roughly speaking Japan
has had zero to no growth since the
early 1990s the high point here was
about a two percent growth very dramatic
contrast to the story that was told in
late 1970s by Ezra Vogel where Japan was
number one this was the most
well-functioning highly producing
economy that he could think of and
that's clearly been a dramatic change
equally in this regard we've seen this
tremendous deflation that has been a at
the heart of much of Japan's economic
problems essentially consumers deciding
that they either cannot afford to buy
something or deciding that if they want
to buy something it's going to be
cheaper tomorrow than it was today or
cheaper next year than before all of
this leads to a slow demand for goods
which cuts into
sales by companies so it's a spiral in
which Japan's economy is somewhat
trapped equally contributing to Japan's
sense of malaise if you want our
economic concern is the fact that many
other economically successful parts of
East Asia notably Taiwan Singapore Hong
Kong South Korea are all now living at
higher standards of per capita GDP than
our citizens in Japan very big
difference from what used to be the case
20 years ago and in something that
clearly raises the hackles of many
Japanese China has now passed Japan in
terms of its total GDP and become the
number two gross domestic product in the
world and finally this is not just an
idiosyncratic aspect but it has very
real human payouts in the sense that
certainly for many of us like myself
who've been going to and from Japan for
many years a big change has taken place
with the fact that you now see rather
substantial areas occupied by the
Japanese homeless lots of middle-aged
men for the most part are out of jobs
homeless living on the streets and one
of these pictures just shows a an
increasingly typical situation in Japan
which is of middle age salary men who
have lost their jobs putting on their
suit every day going to work or
pretending to go to work for the
neighbors for the family sitting in the
park sitting in coffee shops essentially
trying their best to avoid having to
deal with the humiliation of no longer
being part of a productive society so
that's one set of issues that the
declining economy a second that I think
is important is the changing
demographics of Japan Japan for a long
period of time was seeing an increase in
its population largely younger people
lots of people lots of families having
lots of kids and people living longer
but what we're seeing now is a decline
in the population that's projected to go
dropping much more rapidly and basically
a serious decline in the population that
is
equally matched by the fact that it's
also an aging population if you look
here a couple of years ago Japan was
dramatically higher in the proportion of
its people over 65 and as you project
out Japan's situation of the elderly
becomes even more dramatic this is a
country in which basically more and more
people are living longer and longer and
families are having fewer and fewer
children so we have a situation with
more people demanding benefits from the
government fewer people providing the
taxes and let me throw out a third
scenario a snapshot that I think gives
us a handle on some things about Japan
and that is smartphone sales in Japan
here you see Apple going off the charts
for those of you who are holding stock
and Apple you should feel very good
about this on the other hand if you're
holding stock and sony or fujitsu you
should be a bit more worried but the
point of all of this is simply to say
that we're seeing as in that smartphone
area one indication of how foreign
companies are now taking over what used
to be a simply japanese dominated market
equally problematic is the fact that
overseas sales by japanese smartphone
manufacturers are virtually non-existent
it's a market dominated by south korean
american and to some extent european
manufacturers and finally as the last
piece of this i put together the data on
facts use in Japan Japan remains the
world's the industrial world's highest
user of faxes I will not ask how many of
you have sent a fax in the last month or
so but I suspect that there wouldn't be
a whole lot of hands going up but it's
still a very common practice in Japan so
these are three snapshots that I want to
see if i can try tying together the
salvation for japan was supposed to come
with Prime Minister obeys election in
2012 he became very popular in his
public support he has promised something
called abenomics which is to have three
so-called arrows of economic
attack fiscal stimulus monetary
cheapening and ultimately structural
reform of Japan's economy that somehow
will catapult it out of its economic
doldrums solve many of the social
problems and return Japan to the kind of
success that it enjoyed during the 1960s
70s and 80s but equally problematic I
think for many is the question of
whether a bay is really focusing on
abenomics and the economic problems or
to what extent he is really leaning
heavily heavily in the direction of
carrying out a nationalist agenda
carrying out challenges to the Japanese
peaceful Constitution his visits to
Yasukuni Shrine and to the rewrite and
his actions regarding the rewriting of
Japan's history during World War two
have raised the hackles of many in cross
East Asia particularly in South Korea
and China so that is in some respects
the situation that i'm hoping the bulk
of my lecture can help us to get a
handle on or help us to understand i
talked about this notion of a
developmental regime for those of you
who come at it from the political
science side they'll be aspects that
resonate with something called the
developmental state for those of you
don't know what I'm talking about
essentially what I want to suggest is
that Japan had put in place a system
that worked very effectively from the
early 1950s well into the late 1980s in
which several pieces came together very
nicely fit together like pieces in a
jigsaw puzzle a powerful political
machine dominated by the Liberal
Democratic Party but one in which
basically it brought together very
diverse constituencies big business
small business professional associations
all of whom saw their interests being
presented move forward by the LDP and
voters from across the country voted
disproportionately for the LDP while on
the other hand organized labor not
non-governmental organizations and
citizens groups general
what for the most part marginalized and
shot off to support the political left
that was one piece there was also a very
strong bureaucratic apparatus very
talented individuals Japan's best and
brightest wanting to go into the
ministries wanting to focus on the
economic development project that Japan
was carrying forward at the time working
closely with the business community on
the one hand but also working closely
with government agencies on the other
and you had a business structure that
brought together both small and large
businesses that brought together
businesses from across different sectors
again committed to the project of
economic development but importantly
very sensitive to the market basically
Japanese companies were making the
so-called better mousetrap they were
producing goods that could sell overseas
they had enough competition so that they
avoided the worst excesses of national
champions where one company was under
government protection and move forward
but there was no competition and then
finally and often missed I think in the
analysis of how Japan itself was doing
well is the singular importance of the
security relationship with the United
States as one of Japan's major allies
the United States provided open markets
for Japanese goods without demanding
reciprocity and also provided security
and defense for Japan particularly
during the height of the cold war that
left Japan free to keep its budget low
on defense and to focus more on economic
development and the glue in all of this
and I don't want to take us through all
the bits and pieces but just as a couple
of highlights the LDP gave growth and
protection carried out a whole series of
policies that were helpful to big
business in return for which they got
votes and campaign contributions small
business did provide the votes as well
and also made small contributions but
they got protection from both big
business and also from foreign
competition the rural sector provided
large no
votes particularly when Japan was
heavily agricultural in exchange for
which the LVP kept lots of roads going
into the rural areas lots of bullet
trains and other trains moving into the
rural communities kept rice prices very
high by global standards made for a very
decent standard of living for the rural
community and the US of course got gave
its export markets provided defense but
the US had a very strong ally against
China the Soviet Union North Korea
Vietnam etc so as I suggest here it was
a virtuous cycle longer the LDP was in
power the more could carry out
pro-business policies the more carried
out pro-business policies the happier of
business was the more was willing to
contribute contributions that have the
longer the LDP was in power the better
the farmers did the more they were
willing to provide support all of this
provided a system that was prevailing
from nineteen fifty five or so till I
would say the 1990s but importantly
these pieces were all connected to each
other so think of a house of cards think
of a ball of wax but very hard to
disentangle any single piece and change
it without having a cataclysmic effect
on the rest of the pieces in the system
okay what I want to suggest is that
there were three major sets of changes
lots of things go on the world is
complicated but three big changes that I
think help us to understand where Japan
was then and how its facing some of the
problems that it's confronting today the
first of these is simply the end of
global bipolarity China made a number of
economic changes changed its diplomatic
relationships the Soviet Union collapsed
that changed the security dynamic in the
region it also changed the economic
dynamic suddenly countries that no
longer traded with each other under the
bipolar system because of anti-communist
rules etc suddenly were free to move
into one another's markets equally there
was a rise in global capital money began
to flow across borders Japan's economy
which had once been
hermetically sealed off was subject to a
great deal more pressure from the kinds
of global financial markets that we now
summarize by saying four trillion
dollars can cross international borders
in a single day at clicks of a computer
Japan was captured by or moved into that
system more pressures for mergers and
acquisitions more pressures for trade
liberalisation and then a third thing I
want to suggest is what I've called a
dilemmas of success in something I wrote
earlier and that is to say the model
itself was so good at producing the
outcomes that wanted that in many
respects it no longer needed to be or no
longer could continue to be functioning
as well as it had big changes in the
socioeconomic order part of that
demographic problem i talked about
people live longer families no longer as
large as they used to be and japan
became much older became much more
middle-class much more urban than it had
been previously so the questions that I
think Japan has had to face is how do
you adjust that model how do you change
what seems to be a very successful
operating system to one that somehow is
going to be more flexible more adaptable
to the new moves the new pressures that
are going on and how it sent in
essentially did these domestic
conditions begin to challenge or affect
the system that had gone before just one
or two things to highlight on each of
these three pressures the end of
bipolarity again very familiar with it
nixon goes to china but so did tanaka go
to china in 1972 japan normalized
relations south korea ultimately
normalized relations taiwan has had good
relations with china china's become a
magnetic market for investments from all
of the rich parts of East Asia as well
as from the US and Europe and meanwhile
a cold war ended in Europe with the end
of the Berlin Wall global power I
mentioned but a few things here
deregulation in the United States and
the UK
made the financial sectors in both of
these countries but equally in Holland
in Germany elsewhere much more powerful
they wanted to move out expand their
markets they put a great deal of
pressure on Japan similarly the
financial system that had allowed Japan
for so long to maintain that wonderful
exchange rate that so many of us of my
generation benefited from 360 n to the
dollar went out the window Japan's yen
became more and more valuable which
affected negatively its capacity to
export and basically at the same time it
gave Japanese companies more ability to
move overseas to buy at cheap prices
land labor capital in Thailand South
Korea Taiwan etc so many Japanese firms
became much less national than they had
been before all of which undercut the
pre-existing situation and finally just
to highlight a couple of things on the
development the dilemmas of success the
Cold War was one so the LDP which had
long based itself on being an
ideological party necessary for stopping
communism Japanese voters even if they
didn't like the LDP should fear for
their lives vote to keep the Communists
out of Japan vote to keep us safe from
the Soviet Union or China's threat so
whatever suddenly that seemed much less
palatable to the general public the
Japan developed this new middle class
less need to strive less need to get
into work two hours early and stay five
hours late greater willingness to move
away from ketchup economics and the
overall company challenges that were
once catching up to the other
industrialized democracies we're now
confronted with a new problem of how do
you move to the cutting edge how do you
find the next new thing instead of
knowing what the next new thing is going
to be and copying it or imitating it so
in all of these ways I think the old
pattern was changing and the demographic
just to highlight a couple of things
that I've alluded to agriculture and
small business began to shrink fewer
fewer farmers as you can expect fewer
and fewer acres of land devoted to
farming small and medium shops began to
give way to large department stores
service sector etc fewer people working
in this area so fewer people anxious to
support the old political machinery and
meanwhile as i said the aging population
was due to the decline in birth rates on
the one hand and health successes that
meant people could live longer as many
of you probably know japan now has
basically the longest living life
prospects for any industrialized
democracy and what it has meant though
negatively is that in the 1950s there
were 20 workers for every retiree that
moved to seven to one it's now closer to
3 2 1 which means essentially that there
are not a lot of people working and
paying taxes in order to support the
increasing number of people who are
demanding health care retirement
benefits and the like so the salary man
had become by this period of the 1970s
and 1980s the hub of Japan's future
rather than the small businessman of the
farmer and the phrase that was popular
at the time was that every family that
was successful would have the three C's
a car a cooler ie a refrigerator and a
color TV so the dynamic of who Japan
what Japan was like was carried out very
quickly just a couple of highlights on
specific challenges as I said security
and ideology were no longer as unifying
the economic dependence on the US went
down Japanese companies began investing
in South Korea trading with China moving
into Southeast Asia either directly or
through sales the American market which
was once taking 33 or 35 percent of
Japanese exports has dropped to fifteen
sixteen seventeen percent now meanwhile
the u.s. once the coal
over was far less tolerant of the
so-called trade asymmetries you used to
send us this stuff and we didn't demand
access to your market suddenly the US
government and US companies are
insisting that Japan be much more open
in semiconductors and telecommunications
in textiles in goods where Japan
previously enjoyed relatively protected
home markets and so a national economic
isolation began to give way as foreign
companies came in and Japanese companies
moved out but the point of all of this
is simply to say that even though old
institutions and practices are perhaps
no longer as productive as they used to
be they tend to be very sticky
institutions don't change very quickly
and easily any of us who've ever
struggled with trying to make changes in
our lives get rid of bad habits probably
can relate to the the difficulty of that
yes I know I should give up smoking but
let me have another drag or you know
after this one chocolate sundae I'm
going to move on to the Weight Watchers
program with vigor etc and in many ways
that's the metaphorical equivalent of I
think what was going on in Japan at the
time I want to concentrate on two big
challenges and how they play out in the
political economy of the country and
suggest that the first of these I drew a
picture pulled a picture from the
Luddites but be breaking up the
political machine was a fundamental
problem how does how do you deal how did
the LDP as the dominant Conservative
Party get challenged and how did it
begin to deal with us in the abstract it
was very easy for any of us analyzing it
to say the LDP used to be a party of
agriculture small business and some big
business now the voters are more urban
more middle-class how do you move to
attract those new voters agriculture was
under pressure from outsiders to
modernize industrialized to reduce
prices small business under competition
from international businesses but often
also from Japanese businesses that we're
trying to move into rural areas
so all these began to undercut the
support base of the LDP but as I try to
suggest here in this last point while
this might have been rationale for the
party as a whole individual politicians
were very resistant to giving up what
worked in their particular district if
I've got a rural district I don't want
to hear about let's liberalize
agriculture if I'm heavily dependent on
small business for my support I don't
want to hear about the merits of target
or big-box stores or anything of the
sort so you had this tension between the
parties abstract goals and the more
concrete goals of individual politicians
so politics was very slow to respond to
these global changes particularly the
changes in bipolarity particularly the
changes in demographics and basically
the finance ministry resisted all
pressures for financial deregulation a
subject that Francis rosenbluth took up
a number of years ago to great effect
instead the policy was on stimulus
packages let us Keynesian eyes the
economy let's pump a lot of money into
the economy let's build some additional
bridges but in the process you had an
awful lot of these bridges to nowhere
before Sarah Palin even thought about
the idea one particular instance had
three different bridges from untrue the
main island to Shikoku one of the other
islands almost all next to each other
each of them in three different
congressional districts or a
parliamentary districts each one
designed to help a particular
parliamentarian and the you know the
total cost of this the total ferry
service was not enough to to remotely
cover the cost and the ferry service
would have been perfectly fine meanwhile
the interest payments on the
government's increasing debt continued
to go up reducing the capacity of the
government to make independent decisions
about what it wanted to do next in my
view Japan was very much at a crossroads
economically at about nineteen
eighty-five 1985 was
big jump in the Japanese yen again it
moved up by another forty or fifty
percent there was a report issued that
suggested that this was time for Japan
to move from an export-oriented economy
in which you try to sell stuff to
foreigners to a domestically focused
economy in which you make and try to
sell stuff to your consumers even if
that means bringing in foreign goods and
allowing foreign materials to move in
this however was not seen by
beneficiaries of the existing system as
a good idea so what happened instead was
the finance ministry began to drop
interest rates may capital very cheaply
available to everybody and from nineteen
eighty five to nineteen ninety Japan
went through a an incredible asset
bubble this was a period in which
Japan's business leaders individual
citizens were riding high in the firm
belief that Japan could do no wrong land
prices are going to be going up on a
constant basis so we should invest in
land stock prices we're going to
continue to go up so we should buy more
stock if we can borrow money to buy even
more stock that's going to be better it
was a classic case of stocks land art
prices Golf Course memberships all
increasing in value with a seemingly
endless move forward at the beginning
this looks very good the end I suggest
is a little bit more like munch and this
is precisely what has happened to Japan
since for the erstwhile economists in
the group or those who think that
political scientists can't speak about
economics here's my graphic explanation
of what went on taxes began to stay very
low government expenses went up very
high with those bridges with government
subsidies etc and increasingly the
government was borrowing more and more
so that by now government debt is some
in the neighborhood of two hundred and
forty percent of gross domestic product
and the government budget too sir
debt and industry is on the order of a
quarter of the total budget so this this
is a very unsustainable long-term
approach individual companies were
borrowing money they had borrowed money
during this bubble they could no longer
pay it back so many Japanese companies
were known as zombie companies they were
not really producing much not really
making much profit but the banks were
keeping them going so like the zombies
or the walking dead they continued
because to cut them off in the way that
neoliberal economists would have us
believe is the ideal would have meant
rapid unemployment failure companies and
the like equally indicative of the
slowness with which the political
machinery responded is agriculture this
is the proportion of GDP accounted for
by agriculture it's down in the
one-percent range today but Japan still
spends about 65 billion dollars a year
on agricultural subsidies the price of
rice in Japan is still about four times
higher than it is around the world and
for those who follow that trans-pacific
partnership negotiations a big chunk of
the TPP is devoted to providing
agricultural subsidies rather than
completely liberalizing the market one
of the reasons why it's been difficult
for Japan's politics to change this is a
my best effort at graphics but this
shows the length of time that various
political leaders have been in office as
you see in Japan for a long period of
time this was a sequence of nine month
10 months 12 months Prime Minister's the
one exception being Prime Minister
Koizumi whereas in other countries
leaders are frequently in power for
eight years ten years and can actually
carry out some changes so Prime Minister
Koizumi came into power in 2001 stayed
in office for five years and actually
sought to cut out and end an awful lot
of the pork barrel politics that had
existed up until then get the
non-performing loans off the books
require banks to close out these
companies close out the loans cuts in
construction cuts in public works limits
on bod bond issuance
lots of public corporations were
privatized and in his most singular
achievement he tried to privatize the
postal system I don't want to go into a
long discussion of the postal system but
it was one in which the LDP had
benefited tremendously from the savings
of mrs. Yamamoto and mr. Tanaka at the
local level it formed a kind of second
budget that kept them made it possible
for them to carry out a whole lot of
pork oriented slush fund politics he
wanted to cut that out was very
successful in doing it in a very
intriguing story that I don't want to go
into in detail but he was followed in a
short period by a bee shinzo heir to the
LDP as many of you know he was the
grandson of casino bousquet a pre-war
minister who had been originally
convicted of class a war crimes during
world war two was pulled out of prison
and eventually made prime minister by
the American occupiers who were worried
about making sure that there was an
anti-communist force in Japan and obey
came into office talking about Japan as
creating a beautiful nation Japan was
going to be a beautiful nation but as I
want to suggest in the next couple of
slides this was a template on which a
lot of different things could be
projected for many of the beautiful
japan chrysanthemums Zen martial arts
snow-capped mountains cooky OA etc but
for many others a beautiful japan was
just a symbol behind which an awful lot
of Japan's military successes during the
30s or the right-wing orientation of
many in Japan could provide could be
provided cover our base key failure in
my estimation had been his failure to
institutionalize the LDP reforms that
Koizumi had brought forward he
immediately brought into the party a
number of individuals from the old guard
who had been kicked out by koizumi he
wanted to reverse the the privatization
of the postal system he carried out a
whole series of rather
sleazy maneuvers with a number of
retrograde politicians which led to a
rapid decline in the LDP's and his
popularity basically all forced out and
for short period of time Japan was
governed by the completely different
opposition party the Democratic Party of
Japan but that was a party that very
quickly failed carry out a lot of the
reforms they made bad choices on
relations with the United States I with
Futenma no kanawa they had problems with
raising the consumption tax they got
into trouble with China over the
senkaku/diaoyu islands and then of
course they also were in office when the
triple disaster hit japan in march of
1911 the huge tsunami and earthquake and
nuclear meltdown that have devastated
japan for a period so all of those were
challenges to the political machinery
which ave himself now in his second term
is trying quote to rectify unquote
equally important though i think has
been the difficulty of challenging the
so-called greenhouse economy or the
hothouse economy the domestic economy
that had been in place for so long a big
part of this was the rapidly expanding
value of the yen as i said 362 the
dollar was what i had when i was in the
in the marines when I was in Japan when
I was in Japan on my first Fulbright I
felt like a king I could buy a lot of
yen etc the yen has since escalated
through a series of changes to the point
where it was 80 to the dollar for a
while it's now much more 110 or 120 but
substantially stronger than it had been
before in the 1980s at the heart of the
bubble japan went through a huge
overseas purchasing binge buying Pebble
Beach buying parts of Rockefeller Center
buying up assets left right and sideways
and in what is probably apocryphal but
it's it's too good to pass up the value
the land value of the Imperial Palace
which is essentially a circle of five
kilometers surrounding the Imperial
Palace was worth more
are on paper than the entire real estate
value of the state of California so this
clearly should have been telegraphed as
a bubble but it wasn't money flowed in
firms flowed out leaving behind those
companies that had been previously
dependent on big firms for subcontract
work they either had to move themselves
or they lost their business that was a
kind of hollowing out of Japan's
industrial core government influence
over business began to decrease Japanese
firms became if they were successful
they were really much more frequently
globalized and the less competitive
companies were in many cases the ones
that stayed in Japan many of you have
seen the movie No Country for Old Men I
want to suggest to you that this is not
the case in Japan Japan is a country for
old men and increasingly it's becoming a
country that is not very hospitable to
either young men or two women part of
this with regard to young men is
reflected in the dramatic rise in youth
unemployment Japan's unemployment rate
has been going up steadily but it's
falling disproportionately largely on
younger Japanese many of whom are now
serving as so-called frita free auto by
the part-time workers donning bizarre
wigs and carrying unusual signs that
said we're working part-time and much of
this is just a function of the primacy
of age with in Japanese companies
Japanese companies as I'm sure many of
you know traditionally operated on a
principle of so-called permanent
employment the essential theory of which
was we hire you at 21 22 23 you stay
with us until your retirement in your
late 50s or early 60s you will be on an
escalator to success unless you really
foul up badly you will move to the top
you will become a section chief or a
bureau chief or
eventually perhaps CEO and the younger
people will get on that escalator and if
they are patient they will be rewarded
simply by virtue of being with the
company long enough that model has
remained largely intact there had always
been some part-time employment that
always been buffers to soften the the
impact of an absolute and firm
commitment to permanent employment but
we've seen a real jump in the rise of
part-timers in Japan and that has fallen
disproportionately on younger workers
and on women companies have decided to
keep their commitment to the older
workers men now in their 40s or 50s or
60s and not to hire the younger 21 25
year olds and also to continue what has
long been a male-oriented breadwinner
model that has been rather
discriminatory towards serious positions
for women Japan stands out among
industrial countries is one of the least
gender equal of countries around the
world the last index on this had them
ranking 150 hind China the last time I
looked I think they were somewhere
between Sierra Leone and an Iraq but the
point of all of this is that women in
Japan tend to be finding extremely
difficult to move into serious
professional managerial positions very
unlikely that they will move into
successful political leadership
positions and the like the female
employment rate in Japan also very low
by comparison to other industrialized
democracies and Japanese companies here
show up as being very low in their
proportion of female managers and
directors and here extremely low almost
non-existent in their promotion of women
to positions of on the boards of
directors and in super senior positions
it's important I think to note that
Japanese companies
despite the fact that they are often
producing extremely good materials are
extremely inefficient when it comes to
actually meeting productivity goals so
they pit the Japanese worker tends to
put in long hours with very low
productivity lots of time sitting around
because the boss is still there but not
necessarily generating much serious
output so Japan has one of the lowest
GDP hours GDP per hour worked among the
OECD basically ranks between italy and
slovenia and this is partly a function
of those guarantee jobs partly a
function of the long-standing ethos of
being constantly in the office without
necessarily having to produce much and a
last point that i want to pick up is
something that in japan is cynically
discussed as so-called Galapagos tech
for those who have been to galapagos you
will know that there are products there
are animal life there there is animal
life there that is found nowhere else in
the world and this is the perception of
much of Japan's technology it's terrific
it works very well with in Japan but
it's never going to sell overseas
Japanese companies increasingly
manufacturing things for domestic
consumers but without the kind of
previous orientation they had toward
making things that are going to sell
abroad a small byproduct of this has
been the rather somatic rather dramatic
jump in poverty in Japan Japan as I and
several others used to point out had the
very anomalous situation of having a
conservative government but very high
levels of equality as measured by the
Gini index and so forth so Japan in many
ways was about as a gala tarian as
Sweden Denmark Finland Norway etc that
has now changed the u.s. is beginning to
look a lot more like the u.s. a lot more
income inequality a lot more gaps
between the super-rich and the
impoverished so all of this is to say
that that Japan has a lot of serious
problems at the same time as I think we
all know
pan is a country with tremendous assets
it's a very rich thriving industrial
country if you went there today you
would probably feel comfortable riding
on the roads going across the bridges
the infrastructure is sound the bullet
train still comes on time etc Japan is
often at the leading edge of everything
from food to design to architecture and
you know as I'm and not to mention j-pop
anime manga and the kinds of things that
16 and 18 year old Americans are
salivating to get their hands on I've
never quite seen it myself but that's
probably why I'm on this end of the
generation gap than the the other but
but the point of and for somebody from
Berkeley who rides on potholes 24-7 it's
amazing for me to go to Japan and right
in a taxi and not have to hang on to
both sides of the car so to try to bring
this to a semi conclusion a couple of
things I think that are important to
think in mind as I suggested
developmental ism is under challenge but
the adjustments have been very slow to
occur part of this is because you have
not had the political force to carry it
out part of it is that you've not had
the corporate world to carry it out as
one of my cynical American executive
friends said to me he talked to a CEO
aged 65 and a Japanese company said you
know Terry everything you suggest is
really good I'm really going to push for
that kind of change in my company except
the 75 year old boss who hired me is now
CEO and you know I can't really do
anything until he steps away and he's
reluctant to move ahead because the 90
year old found or the company still
comes in you know still comes in four
days a week and checks in to see how
everything's going so it's been very
tough for companies to make a lot of
these changes and large parts of the
Japanese economy are still very
comfortable lots of Japanese live very
well lots of Japan functions extremely
efficiently so the sense of crisis
temptation is is less tempting than
perhaps it might be in other places I
want to suggest in a broad metaphorical
sense that
one way to think about the situation in
Japan over the last 20 25 years is to go
back to kubler-ross his sense of notion
of the five stages of grief for the five
stages of knowing about your death the
first is denial Japan certainly went
through this in the early 90s nothing
bad is happening with Japan we've got
the perfect solution just get out of our
way let us go back to doing what we're
doing a certain amount of anger what's
this China thing coming up you know we
can't take that seriously the Koreans
are selling more cell phones we can't
believe that etc bargaining maybe we can
cut a deal maybe we can change this but
not the other right now I think Japan is
very heavily in a mode of depression
Japan is going to sink into the sea we
have no population growing life is bleak
etc maybe there's going to be enough
acceptance so that eventually Japan will
move forward and begin to make some of
the additional changes that I think are
going to be beneficial both to the
political and the economic system so let
me stop on that note see if I've got any
comments questions whether I've
triggered singular animosity and
hostility from anybody out there but one
I take any questions or comments
and we can't go to the drinks before 620
anyway so you might as well ask
questions if you have any oh sorry I did
that was meant as a joke rich yes oh
sorry hi thank you very much of this
talk it was put a lot of things in great
perspective I'm curious how you see the
trans-pacific partnership process on the
Japanese side a lot of us watch it on
the US side and I've tried to watch the
Japanese side but I don't have the tools
really to look at it has a Bayes team in
overcoming some of the domestic
opposition we think you know started
some of those structural changes that
you've identified as being necessary i
guess for the last 20 years or so right
now i think i mean i think that's that's
quite accurate i mean i think ave japan
generally obey in particular was a bit
hesitant to sign on to the trans-pacific
partnership which as many of you
probably know is a 12 country free trade
agreement that would attempt to reduce
tariffs and reduce barriers to economic
integration among a number of countries
the United States Japan of Vietnam
Malaysia Australia etc and for Japan
this would mean a great deal of change
my sense is that obey and the Japanese
business community have signed on to
this for two reasons one is still the
security relationship they still want a
great hug from the United States and I
think the US perception that this is a
security related economic manifestation
is very real so I think there was a
worry if Japan did not join that it
might alienate itself somewhat from the
United States but I think I bay for
everything I've read about TPP in Japan
is really moving to introduce some
serious structural changes which
probably will be of great benefit to the
economy as it as
moves forward all it gets implemented
and right now the Japanese are beginning
to put pressure on the United States to
say what happened you guys thought you
were the leaders of this now Trump's
against it Cruz's against it Clinton's
against its Anders against it you know
can Obama bring this thing together we
thought we were following your lead how
do we get out front but I think it's
also important as I tried to elude here
that there are still some built-in
protections within Japan so that this is
not going to be draconian market reforms
there are going to still be a lot of
built-in protections for Japan which I
frankly think of probably not bad ideas
I mean one of the worst things about
some of the free trade agreements that
have put in place before are the are the
people that are left behind and I think
Japan is doing its best as it often has
to try and make sure that those who are
most negatively affected are going to
find some solace from the government
it's not simply going to be G the market
has spoken you're out of luck so so I
think that's the way it's been playing
out ok don't one right next to you call
them i right here in the front since
we're moving the mic up ok the woman
with the Yale shirt on yeah thank you I
have a question about Japan's
immigration policy so in face of the
Asian problem do you think Japan would
somehow change their immigration policy
to allow like foreigners and to increase
the working population in turn right
again a very good question i mean i
think a lot of people in Japan are
debating this if Japan is aging rapidly
and its really got a smaller tax base
how do you deal with that one way to
deal with it and certainly one that's
been very popular in the United States
is a relatively generous policy toward
immigration one of the things that keeps
the American tax base solid is the fact
that we do have a reasonably large
number of immigrants coming into the
country on a year-by-year basis Japan
very much the opposite it's very
difficult for
individuals to emigrate to Japan Japan
has not been a home for Refugees for
example etc and this is the debate that
goes on very constantly in Japan right
now I think my sense of this is if Japan
wants to increase the number of workers
and the productive workers it still has
two very good avenues to move down that
might help solve this one is moving more
women into the workforce in full and
honest full-time work and taking
advantage of the fact that fifty percent
of the population happens to be female
but a second thing is making it possible
for and encouraging lots more young
people to be free to pursue individual
creativity etc Japan is not a country
that has traditionally fostered three
guys in a garage with a creative idea
coming up with the next Facebook or the
next Twitter or the next snapchat or
whatever it is and that I think is
something that Japan is lacking war
Japan to begin making moves in those
directions by making it easier for women
to get into the workforce etc I think
they could solve some of their problems
will let's move in the direction of
changing immigration policy I think
that's probably going to be the third
and least desirable direction for Japan
to go because it still runs up against
very strong prejudices that think in
terms of foreigners not being able ever
to adjust to Japan I mean I'm still
astonished when I you know when I get
out into the rural areas every once in a
while some little kid will run out see
me and run like hell in the other
direction screaming guide you engaging
guide you in a foreigner you know
there's there's still that ethnic
homogeneity that I think is very strong
in Japan it's very tough to to resist
but it's something that I think some
Japanese companies are exploring and as
you may or may not know lots of Japanese
policies now make it possible for work
to come into Japan for two years three
years it's allegedly for training it's
also cheap labor for a lot of companies
for low-end manufacturing work
I think there was a question here do you
want to give her the micro just I was
projecting but could you talk a little
more about Japan's role in Southeast
Asia I how I sees itself regionally I
mean TPP makes us think that this
us-japan relations is still the main
focal point but how it has in fact
Japan's change in status changes
perspective you know what should do in
the region yeah again a good question a
very interesting one knob I think
generally speaking I think Japan
particularly during the 70's and 80's
saw itself as the leading economic model
for the rest of Asia including Southeast
Asia to follow the Koreans finally got
the message the Taiwanese have got the
message they're doing what we have done
and they're moving in the right
direction Southeast Asia increasingly I
think turned to Japan for advice for a
model could be tweaked could be changed
but certainly Malaysia under mchottie
awaz very anxious to embrace Japan look
east etc etc and that meant that he
didn't have to worry about Jewish
bankers which always seemed to worry him
as well these would least be Japanese
bankers who were presumably different
Indonesia Thailand very much recipients
of japanese foreign direct investment
going out so I think Japan and Malaysia
is now still an asari said Malaysia min
Mars now a country in which there's a
lot of Japanese involvement both foreign
aid etc in many ways I think this is is
driven by pure economics Japanese firms
that are anxious to take advantage of
cheaper labor plus often very good
technological and human resource
infrastructure in Southeast Asia I mean
tons of english-speaking Singaporeans or
Hong Kong residents or ties who are
comfortable with japan etc so i think a
lot of it's driven by economics but i
think increasingly the japanese
government is thinking of itself is
playing a competitive game with china
which of us can be the more influential
with Southeast Asia and so now you're
starting to see that play out with
things like Japan sending Coast Guard
cutters to the Philippines or to
Indonesia because of what
philippinen Indonesian government CES
potential Chinese threats to their
maritime territories the Japanese are
quickly saying hey we got some Coast
Guard cutters for you you go fight the
Chinese so I think it's now got both
dimensions working for it and I think
Japan is doing its best in terms of
Foreign Affairs to keep a very strong
toehold in Southeast Asia thank you so
much TJ that really was panoramic and my
job so I hope you still have questions
we're all going to go together to the
reception upstairs where you'll have a
chance to talk more with your buzzer pen
pal thank you again